CNN is continuing to stand by a story
that one of the people who sourced it
says might be false in July CNN broke
news that Donald Trump was aware of that
famous meeting with the Russian lawyer
inside Trump Tower before the meeting
happened this would be potentially
significant Lanny Davis lawyer
representing Michael Cohen says he was
the source for that story and then he
admitted he doesn't really know if it's
true he can't back it up CNN says it has
other sources for the story though it
hasn't revealed who they might be last
night on this show journalist Glenn
Greenwald explained CNN's reticence to
backtrack on an obviously false story I
find it to be and obviously this is a
high bar one of the most humiliating and
scandalous moments and the entire media
behavior of the Trump Russia saga and
they don't want to admit that they lied
to the world so they're they can't
retract the story and they can't admit
they lied so they're just continuing to
stick to what everybody knows of the lie
but not many people care because people
think a lot of people anyway that it was
done for the right political agenda Alan
Dershowitz is an emeritus professor of
law at Harvard Law School he's the
author of the case against impeaching
Trump and he joins us tonight professor
thank you for coming on so watching the
CNN saw a guy keep and by the way you
know lots of news organizations get
stories wrong I've gotten stories wrong
my complaint is really first that
they're not telling us what happened but
more than that would it be significant
if the story were true in other words if
the president knew this meeting with
this Russian lawyer was about to take
place
should any of us care does that matter
is that illegal is it unethical well
it's certainly not illegal the president
is certainly entitled to know about a
meeting between his son and somebody who
wanted to give him dirt on a candidate
or who wanted to talk to him about maybe
changing rules involving sanctions those
are open you know perfectly proper
meetings but CNN is in a box I want to I
want to put the best possible light on
it let's assume it has one or two other
sources in addition to Lanny Davis who
did the right thing by coming forward
charging that his story he doesn't have
any support for his story but they can't
reveal their sources and I have to
suggestions for them number one that
they tell us the nature of the sources
without telling us the names are they
eyewitnesses is it a hearsay source or
second that they give the source to
their expert on journalism and let their
expert decide whether or not they should
stick with the story or some outside
expert somebody from the Columbia School
of Journalism who could learn the name
of the sources then go talk to the
sources still keep their names
confidential right and then come forward
and say you know there is a basis we're
standing behind CNN they have to do
something to preserve their credibility
well sure I mean all these organizations
asked them all of us call for
transparency that's our job so we should
provide it when asked and they're not so
you wrote a piece recently that reminded
me anyway that you're not that I know
that you have been typecast as a Trump
defender but you're not a Trump defender
you're a liberal and I think that a lot
of problems with Trump but in the piece
you made a really interesting point I
thought you said that our system of
checks and balances is out of whack
because of the independent prosecutor
and his investigation tell us what you
meant that's absolutely right look
everybody's checking everybody else
under the kind of Madisonian system of
checks and balances that have served us
so well the courts is striking down
executive orders sometimes upholding
them yes the president's check in
Congress Congress particularly if the
Democrats get control we'll check the
presidency but who's guarding the
guardians who is overseeing the special
counsel or other overzealous prosecutors
the courts aren't doing it the there's
no there's no process that today exists
and I suggested the appointment of a
permanent a group to oversee
prosecutorial overreaching it could
include great former prosecutors like
Robert Morgenthau the legendary DA of
New York right it can include ethics
expert like Stephen gillers the
professor at Columbia constitutional
experts like Floyd Abrams and they would
have the opportunity to at least file
reports about prosecutorial overreach
because today the special counsel is the
only institution of government outside
of our system of checks and balances
whoever thought that up is insane I hope
you live forever because we need people
to thank you professor thank you very
much turning 80 in two days so I'm on my
way please keep going we appreciate it
thank you